when you've got parallel lines like a B
and C D Thea right we've got these
parallel lines there are what a great
patterns hiding all over the place and
you notice some of them for instance
there's lots of corresponding angles and
you might recall I said they kind of
look like this so some people call
corresponding angles they call on
bangles I didn't make that up trust me
that's the kind of shape that you get
from these corresponding angles because
you can see they're pointing in the same
direction if you've got alternate angles
they kind of look like this share this
that's one of the films they can take so
some people like to call them can you
guess Zhang goes right we've got bangles
we've got dangles we've got one last one
that i'm going to show you this lesson
question here okay well you can wait
because you don't want to be that guy in
the in the arm in the movie theater when
everyone rolls here and like the movie
starts and it sounds like that's the bad
guy and everyone's like ah you just
ruined my i just paid ten bucks there's
nothing that's cool you want to be
spoiler free in this classroom okay so
okay now what you see is let's pick out
some angles here and notice some
relationships because you remember I got
alternate angles I got these out of
corresponding games once you know these
you know these may you you actually form
them together we could do something
similar here have a look at this angle
I'm marketing in here what's its name
what's its name brunette case okay the
size is abuse glad you made it the kind
of angle is is obtuse but it actually
has a name here in this diagram ADA
melted angle a QP would do it has
other name i could use what else could i
call it p QA they're both fighting right
they both got the arms and they've got
the vertex in the right spot in the
middle all good let's write that down
together angle and Cupid okay now which
angle corresponds to a QP which is the
corresponding angle so this one Amy C ah
q perfect they go right and you can see
again it's because they're facing in the
same direction I've been trying so hard
all week to avoid saying that they're
facing in the same direction so that's
what makes it possible now what I was
good it is you think about all these
different things you know about angles
and try to start putting together for
instance when you look at a QP again I
can see all right there's a 20 in your
van is a vertically opposite angle there
I particularly want to draw your
attention to this angle that's just next
to it now we have a special word we used
to say next two starts in an age does
anyone remember McGillis adjacent this
angle here that I just put in blue dots
a qs r is adjacent so therefore i notice
that because these angles are adjacent
and they honor what is this PS what is
that it's a straight line right it's
straight angle so adjacent angles on
here they should add up to something
right what do those angles on there add
up to molly's that hand up or I'm just
stretching that's okay in your hopes up
okay this whole legal here in fact I'd
love you to mark this in with me who's
this this whole angle all the way is 180
degrees I suppose if you like you can
also say why it's because it's a
straining it's half of a revolution
now because I've been eating I'm going
to put all of this together right move
everything too young Hagel a QP the red
one the top red one it's equal to angle
see our cue that was the first thing we
said what was the reason the reason
what's the relationship between is to
read angle somebody hasn't said anything
yet all right I know lots of us know
lots of snow yeah yeah that's the
question is these are equal but why why
is it the very cool do you want to try
to have a stab at it facing the same
direction once a call starts with the
sea or on Potter very good we got there
ok it was on the tip of your tongue
right yeah their corresponding angle so
let's let's give the reason here ok I'm
going to put my number because up run
out of a bit of species commerce party
angles on what do they call again these
two lines I've given them names a B and
C DS i'm going to say corresponding
angles on these two lines which are
parallel because there's my parallel
light signal corresponding angles on
those are eaten that's good okay but I'm
actually the same to work but as you
just noticing what i put in green there
is that a QP plus the adjacent angle the
blue tide one what's it called again
what do we name it would you like to
name this angle I was like to call it
yeah thank you r and q are double do it
and what a QP plus angle AQ r is equal
to 100 years it's a whole green angle if
i put them together you get that green
angle does that make sense and the
reason why is because i can have any
number of rain was there if you add them
together all of the ones there for three
or four or five or 100 they'll all that
up 280 so we've said that they add up to
injuries and the reason is because the
angle song of a straight line or a
straight angle straight angle do is 180
degrees do you remember i showed you
before how the reason always matches up
to the equation or the statement that
you go with it right so these two are
the angles on the straight line and I'm
saying they are equal to 180 degrees
done so now I want you to see how I can
pull this together okay if you don't
look at this second line here I'll put a
red star if you have a look at this like
year do you see then i can say angle aqr
the blue dotted one is equal to 180
degrees take away the angle i started
with do you see that like can I take the
angle and subtract it from both sides do
you see what I've done okay so if i take
this line and it's a balance now
equation they're both the same in both
sides so if i do the same thing to both
sides we're all still group I've taken
this away from both sides so that's why
it disappears off here is only one angle
down instead of two and it's a pure here
on the right hand side but hold on look
at this right angle AQ r are at sorry oh
thank you yeah they got AQ huh that's
art that's this one here it's related to
this angry now the red and the blue
angles are related to each other let me
try and show you how this angle key is a
hundred and eighty degrees take away a
QR right what's the single down here
equal to that's just equal to x you a QP
up here right to see that sorry
so when you have a look at these two
angles together the ones in the middle
right we have a word fitness when you
add them together what will you get when
you add those two angles together this
to hear 180 degrees take away a QP and
if i add it to angle a cute hey what
happens perhaps that pair of angles on
the end there if you have a number like
a hundred right you take away 5 and your
ad fun what do you get what happens to
yeah yeah you just come back to this guy
right like these two I guess what I
would say is they cancel each other out
right so they both eliminate the crash
and you end up with this right now I
don't even know what the size of this
angle is but they're the same science do
you notice that so therefore these guys
are going to cancel each other out just
going to end up with 180 degrees okay
you have a name for this it starts with
s we looted it this morning what happens
when you got a pair of angles and you
add them together and you get 180
degrees remember yeah Daniel
supplementary we call these two angles
supplementary
whatever size they are and I want you to
look at your page I want you to have a
look at the paint of the person next to
you those two M's are always going to
out every single time to 180 degrees
okay so therefore I want to conclude
down here and I'd be fun uh yeah you
can't do it
okay these two angles that are both on
the inside right do you see how they're
both on the inside parallel line I guess
I've got another pair of ear right
because they are both inside we call
them co interior that's actually what Co
means you know when people are
cooperating it means they are both
working together reader when you say
somebody's coordinated it means it's
like yeah your arms and your legs work
together so the things that are co
interior interior just means on the
inside right so you've got both of these
annual on the inside and they are
supplementary that's our conclusion okay
so whatever this answer this angry is I
mean what does that angle look like how
big does on this is angle look like to
you someone give me an estimate yeah
yeah I pretend i think is pretty good
entertainer under 20 something like that
if I said I drink 10 this one here then
what would the other angle equal to if
they're supplementary someone else to
and saving someone what else yeah
Bradley or 210 wait hold on a second
what a supplementary mean again it means
they add to add remaining right yeah I
need something else yeah that's okay
Petra Nash okay 70 degrees which by the
way it doesn't look like about 70
doesn't it you we know that a right
angle is 90 degrees and that's going to
be a little bit less thumbs up so this
is our last thing we had bangles their
corresponding we had Zhang girls that
are altered wrong color what would you
call this what does it look like when
you have angles that are both to get
love ya I call them candles okay thank
Jose most anglers you've got
corresponding they face the same way
you've got alternate they face opposite
way
you got co interior they're both on the
inside sort of nestling together and
they are not they're not equal watch out
they're not equal they are in fact
supplementary so they're not the same
size okay